[Applaus]
[Musik]
mischa und christian haben afrika für
ein paar tage verlassen und sind mit
ihrem chef pilot aldo nach kanada
geflogen
in montreal haben sie für ihre
rettungsflugwacht eine zweite pilatus
pc-12 gekauft dass sich die neue pc 12
und kaufte anders sind die neue lokation
pc gekauft haben die montreal und jetzt
ist ihr gefühl nach
die überführung einer so kleinen
maschine ist kompliziert montreal und
botswana sind über 12.000 kilometer
entfernt der tank dieser
propellermaschine reicht aber nur für
knapp 1000 kilometer
deshalb fliegt chef pilot also mit
diversen zwischenstopps über den
atlantik nach europa von dort aus nach
ägypten und schließlich nach botswana
mischa und christian fliegen als
passagiere mit der flug ist aber vor
allem für den piloten also eine große
herausforderung und auch nicht ganz
ungefährlich
die vorbereitung ist sehr wichtig
niemals etwas passiert und das wasser
wäre ziemlich kalt du bist in einem ort
der für jede art von rettungsteam sehr
schwierig zu erreichen ist weit weg von
rein und falls etwas passieren sollte
sind wir auf uns alleine gestellt
[Musik]
die reise führt über grönland nach
island schottland und italien bis nach
luxor in ägypten nur wenige piloten
machen jemals so eine reise und es ist
definitiv etwas an das ich mich mein
ganzes leben lang erinnern werden auch
jonas hat einen wichtigen tag vor sich
heute beginnt die schweizer
meisterschaft im segelkunstflug für die
teilnahme in der höchsten kategorie
unlimited hat der schweizer
hoffnungsträger das letzte halbe jahr
hart trainiert vor einer woche hat jonas
dann erfahren dass er der einzige pilot
in dieser kategorie ist ein eigentlicher
wettkampf findet deshalb nicht statt und
jonas darf nur außer konkurrenz starten
wie die lok betrieb in die ganze welt
die die damen und herren punkte ich
denen der chef punktrichter ist stört
dass sie steht das letzte sagen hat
beim briefing dann die große
überraschung
jonas wird heute doch nicht außer
konkurrenz fliehen
jetzt erfahre dass sie doch mal
konkurrent haben zwar eine
weltmeisterschaft auf was jetzt noch mal
spannend
er hat jetzt mit dem österreichischen
piloten natürlich in konkurrenz
und dann wird es ermöglichen drugs and
pakistan and gegen wickmayer ein
österreichischer pilot hat sich im
letzten moment noch angemerkt
er startet vor jonas und fliegt sein
erstes programm
[Musik]
die jury am boden entscheidet ob die
figuren präzise und elegant geflogen
werden wer mehr punkte erzielt hat
gewonnen
nur gut
jonas und sein trainer thorsten
beobachten den österreicher genau und
mit einer kleinen portion schadenfreude
schulterwurf
am anderem alles vorweg dennoch gibt es
nicht folgen will sich schon mit 20 oder
der konkurrent hat sich ein paar patzer
erlaubt eine gute ausgangslage für jonas
der zum ersten mal in dieser höchsten
kategorie startet zwar kann er heute
keinen titel gewinnen weil zwei
teilnehmer immer noch zu wenig sind aber
er kann seine punkte mit dem
konkurrenten vergleichen und seine
leistung einordnen
windisch prognosen fliegt
[Musik]
da wohl nichts mit sanktionen gehortet
jawohl nachgesteuert
[Musik]
er war mit terrorisiert 72 punkte übrig
geblieben oder armstrong provisions
nicht schlecht
[Musik]
das war ein ist das mit der spitze in
tasche wenig schaffung flug vor allem
will ich denke der kec flüge das einzige
team ohne gurt kann habe ich den flug
macht der kann definitiv schon flüge
was die jury meint erfährt jonas erst am
nächsten tag nach einem zweiten flug
eine letzte chance hatte also noch anna
hat sich spontan entschieden ihren
freund in thun zu besuchen die
überraschung ist gelungen
jonas freut sich über die unterstützung
[Gelächter]
was würdet ihr die freundin das
mitmachen was gemacht dass sie so
verständnisvolle wettbewerben grund und
ich finde es cool wenn sie sich trotzdem
macht erklären und sie anmerkt dass nur
isoliert sind
auch wenn es menschen viel über seine
flüge im us bundesstaat colorado ist das
wetter genauso schlecht wie die laune
der beiden tornado jäger dominik und
sascha ihre vielversprechende
gewitterzelle hat sich vor ihren augen
in luft aufgelöst
bin jetzt am richtigen ort und auf zwei
selten
ein jahr lang haben die zwei freunde für
diese dreiwöchige reise gespart
das ziel war es ein paar tolle fotos
eines tornados nach hause zu bringen
doch bis heute haben die beiden nur
regen und wolken gesehen
[Musik]
mittleres da vielleicht
naja die knappen aus im sommer keine der
mautstraße schlagen
dominik und sasha waren einmal mehr in
richtung dämpfer im norden von colorado
sei die tornado wahrscheinlichkeit
momentan sehr groß sagen unsere
berechnungen tatsächlich braut sich ein
sturm zusammen
die beiden entdecken direkt vor ihnen
eine gewitterzelle
haben die beiden tatsächlich einen
möglichen tornado vor sich von einem
tornado spricht man erst wenn die luft
spirale auch tatsächlich den boden
berührt
station vorgeworfen
nachdem ich sie darauf die irre
[Musik]
[Applaus]
aber das konto wird es aber nur ein foto
würde dominik schon reichen
jetzt lebt die erste klasse nach also
ich wirklich will kann auf jahren 500
meter zurück
die neue pc 12 der okavango rescue ist
inzwischen über dem mittelmeer
kurz vor ekel chef pilot aldo und seine
beiden passagiere mischa und christian
sind seit fünf tagen unterwegs
nach vielen zwischenstopps legen sie in
luxor eine pause ein
[Musik]
bis in luxor in ägypten wir sind gestern
restore nicht locker und jetzt warten
wir doch das mitmischen
vor zwei wochen dieses arabischer
trinkgeld wird vielleicht sogar nötig
seien
aldo kann keine alternativ route nach
botsuana finden
also wir können saudi arabien auch
vergessen es dauert einen monat und
vielleicht eine überflugs erlaubnis zu
bekommen
ich schaue nun ob ich etwas vom sudan
höhere und lasst es euch wissen ja wir
müssen einfach war
wir werden sehen was passiert und
schauen dann weiter
seit vier jahren lebt familie moser aus
dem kanton bern hier in osttimor in
südostasien
einem der ärmsten länder der welt
daniel arbeitet hier als missions- pilot
bei der christlichen hilfsorganisation
nf familie das ehepaar diskutiert oft ob
und wann sie in die schweiz zurück gehen
wollen
deborah macht sich gedanken darüber wie
sony wie aufwächst
ich glaube ein trinker zaugg hat es
schwierig sich in pflanzen wo für den
ist das hier das ist mir diese blätter
wie lange sie mal hier bin ich
[Musik]
familie moser ist wegen daniels job nach
osttimor gezogen der rettungsboot fliegt
täglich einsätze auf der insel ein flug
transport kann hier über leben und tod
entscheiden wer und schwarze schuhe und
ja der glaube darum das zelt minute
daniel ist immer allein mit der kleinen
propellermaschine unterwegs so kann er
möglichst viele passagiere und
medizinisches personal transportieren
[Musik]
die schwangere frau war bis zum
flugplatz um sechs stunden unterwegs
sie braucht dringend ärztliche hilfe
respekt vor ford transporter ist es echt
sondern fenster machen
[Musik]
die geburt steht kurz bevor
ob mutter und kind die komplikationen
überstehen wird daniel erst am nächsten
tag erfahren
seine aufgabe als rettungs pilot endet
für heute
vor ein paar wochen im sanktgallischen
andwil waren stephan und sein copilot
ums voller vorfreude
sie wollten die sonnenfinsternis in
argentinien aus ihrem heißluftballon
heraus beobachten
tunis in dem ruf gerne mal der mondnacht
konnten zwischen ihnen und jetzt gibt es
einen moment lang man wo der mond
verdeckt und der mond genau charter
macht daraufhin klinnert punkt auf der
erde und deutet eine stunde für stunde
ist mit dieser expedition will sich
stefan einen herzenswunsch erfüllen eine
totale sonnenfinsternis aus dem
heißluftballon zu sehen
diese chance gibt es wahrscheinlich nur
einmal im leben
[Musik]
heute ist es soweit zusammen mit 50
anderen piloten möchte sich stefan
diesen unglaublichen moment auf keinen
fall entgehen lassen
die totale sonnenfinsternis wird zwei
minuten jene zwei minuten muss zur
rechten zeit am rechten ort termin ist
so dass man am halbe 60 führen die der
luft sind und dann haben wir die
demokratie führen fünf jahren mit der
ballon aufblasen aufheizen so dass jedem
halbe 60 /
[Musik]
bei schlechtwetter zitrone harmoniert
totale finsternis
[Applaus]
ursprünglich ist wie in dem sie das
stück gar nicht umhin abidi richteg
richtet sich perfekt sie die meisten
gaucho auf platz sechs in der tabelle
ist ein sehr plötzlich und schlager auf
dem tisch
und darum sind mehr unterliga komplett
falsch sind die windigsten york gab von
oben direkt unter wahrung der
gewinnkraft einer uns stellen meinte
schaal das ist unsinn
wenn ich schon gewünscht
70 damit stellt die rauslassen
wir hatten in die luft sie nicht drehen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die 20 teams müssen ihre ballone so
schnell wie möglich neu platzieren
sonst wird es zu dunkel um überhaupt
noch rechtzeitig starten zu können
loslassen wir machen hier raus stefan
gehört zu den erfahrensten piloten auf
dem platz er rennt von balkon zu balkon
um den anderen zu helfen
später kann ich auch über pick up and
für deine 115 fehlen
sind sie oft als haustier ist
grundsätzlich vernünftig im ofen teil
der kosten sitzen
olaf bahnhof geld
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ein paar ballonpiloten haben es
geschafft sie sind in der luft stephan
und sein team gehören nicht dazu
ab dem moment halbe stunde früher
gestartet
aber jetzt ist der fall kommt der name
ist nicht klar aber klar wir suchen
sowie der pick-up holen denn dort hat
die fangquote für den pick-up auf wenn
ich einfach nochmal verharrte wie im
moment
ein letzter versuch das gewicht des
autos soll den ballon so lange wie nötig
am boden behalten aber direkt neben
stefan startet bereits ein anderer und
der versperrten den weg
stefan versucht zu helfen um endlich
selber starten zu können
komm her jetzt müsst ihr aufhören
ich weiß jetzt nicht was hier passiert
[Applaus]
auch dieser ballon schafft es noch in
die luft nur stefan bleibt auf dem boden
zu
[Musik]
in luxor wartet das team der okavango sq
seit zwei tagen auf eine überflug
bewilligung aus dem sudan
heute ist der 29 wir sind gegründet wir
haben keine chance hier wegzukommen
[Musik]
pilot also kann sich nicht erklären
warum die bewilligung so lange auf sich
warten lässt bis er die nachrichten
einschaltet
[Musik]
im sudan startet die opposition einen
zweitägigen streik gegen das
militärische der streik erklärt das
schweigen der behörden und verheißt
nichts gutes
also versucht man sich anderweitig zu
unterhalten
[Musik]
mai
der nächste wettkampftag im tun
jonas macht sich für seinen zweiten
flugbereit luftdruck kann seine freundin
anna ist als moralische stütze mit dabei
gilt
[Musik]
beim gestrigen flug waren zu viele
patzer drin heute muster 25-jährige
perfekt fliegen um neben seinem
erfahrenen konkurrenten aus österreich
nicht unterzugehen
[Musik]
auch heute ist jonas nicht ganz
zufrieden mit seiner leistung aber die
entscheidung liegt jetzt ganz bei den
punktrichtern kategorie gibt es gibt
eigentlich nicht denn er streute sondern
sg siegen und der zweite der zweite der
sieger die dritte und letzte sieger
jonas jonas hat mehr punkte bekommen als
ein österreichischer konkurrenz selbst
er ist ein bisschen überrascht
[Applaus]
der strenge juror chance erklärt warum
der schweizer trotzdem gewonnen hat die
rolle sagt 70 straffungen kommt und das
waren 1 ja ja wir sehen ja hast ihm
sehen hier auch die leiche nur gesagt
wirklich ausbaufähigen wo alle fälle
und wenn er bleibt würde ich ihn
international dem nächsten
wenn sie das freut mich natürlich sind
dass das nicht so ist dass sie die miete
bis überfällig hatten schon gar
danke schön
jonas kann sich jetzt in ruhe auf die
weltmeisterschaft im nächsten jahr
vorbereiten
und vielleicht war dieser tat ja der
anfang einer großen karriere in osttimor
ist mission speedo daniel auf dem weg
ins spital
er will dort die patienten besuchen die
er in den letzten tagen im flugzeug
transportiert hat
die medizinische versorgung hier in
osttimor steht in keinem vergleich zur
schweiz dadurch 16 prozent des
kraftstoffs christus auch und denke ich
mir dass die süße frucht hier daniel
besucht das spital nur selten die
schicksale gehen ihm oft zunahm
er trifft den elfjährigen jungen aus
samen den er mit akutem dengue fieber
ins spital geflogen hat es geht ihm
schon viel besser
im raum nebenan liegt das baby das kaum
mehr atmen konnte daniel erkennt die
eltern wieder daniel erkundigt sich auch
nach der schwangeren frau vom vortag
das kind ist also gestorben
und die mutter hat sie überlebt das ist
gut so witzig wie ich mir jetzt sorgen
die ordnung aber ich habe mir dann vor
mir viel über die anderen zwar nicht
sehr gut oder gut überlebt hat er will
nur soviel strom verloren
das leben als rettungs pilot ist kein
einfaches aber daniel hat sich bewusst
dafür entschieden und seine frau deborah
unterstützt ihn auf diesem weg die
schönen seiten dieses armen landes
trösten die beiden immer wieder über ihr
heimweh und die vielen entbehrungen
hinweg
irgendwann war ich noch mit sie zurück
mit der ebay trio mit der genossenschaft
war die zustimmung der umsatz machen
nach schmidts fahrer können
und so wird familie moser diesen weg
noch eine weile gehen damit daniel den
einheimischen aus der luft helfen kann
mit der unterstützung ganz oben
der mond schiebt sich immer mehr über
die sonne bald herrscht über den
argentinischen anden eine totale
sonnenfinsternis die letzten
heißluftballons sind gestartet aber
stephan und sein team sind noch am boden
und dort werden sie auch bleiben nachdem
sie endlich genug platz hatten war es
bereits zu dunkel um sicher zu starten
[Musik]
so auch
[Applaus]
[Musik]
er wirkte sehr emotionaler moment
wirklich halten den moment also und den
abteilungen aber transkei züchtet wenn
lampion
[Musik]
glücklicherweise sind 56 ballonstart und
hängt grüne da beobachtet
[Musik]
sicherheit ist sicher erster stelle da
nur man hat ihm auch realistisch
vernünftigsten diese chance hat stefan
verpasst dafür kehren er und sein team
gesund nach hause zurück
[Musik]
in luxor sind mittlerweile fünf tage
vergangen
aber heute morgen haben mischa christian
und also endlich gute nachrichten
bekommen die überflugs erlaubnis für den
sudan ist eingetroffen
jetzt kann die neue pilatus pc-12 die
letzte etappe nach botswana antreten
[Musik]
zwei wochen waren sie unterwegs 12.000
kilometer luftlinie von montreal kanada
nach botswana afrika hier kann die pc-12
nun ihren neuen zweck erfüllt patienten
transportieren und leben retten
[Musik]
das team der okavango rs cube hat
menschen und maschinen schon sehnsüchtig
erwartet so viele emotionen der terms
geschafft und jetzt wird mir erst
bewusst
wir haben es tatsächlich geschafft
die rettungsflugwacht vom okawango hat
nun ein zweites transportflugzeug noch
ein wenig farbe und dann passt die pc-12
perfekt zur flotte
[Musik]
in den usa bahnt sich etwas großes an
erneut deutet vieles darauf hin dass der
große augenblick ganz nah ist
konkretes land rasch ins tor
bonn
er stand da
tornado
und tatsächlich direkt vor ihren augen
setzt der wirbel auf dem boden auf und
ist zum richtigen tornado geworden
die beiden storm chaser haben ihr ziel
erreicht ihren eigenen kleinen
wirbelsturm
auf meine frage nach anbieter nicht hier
kann man das nicht unbedingt dass er an
bord denn ich habe mir das einfacher
infrastruktur
jetzt eine schöne von artikeln
der kontakt bestehen dass ich ja
für diese fotos sind die beiden um die
halbe welt gereist und tagelang durch
die usa gefahren
da wird sogar sascha etwas emotional
das ist
über 10.000 kilometer im auto unzählige
stunden vor dem computer und unendlich
viel geduld haben sich gelohnt
dominik möchte diesen erfolgsmoment als
erstes mit der familie zu hause teilen
[Musik]
naja aber trocken
die natur hat sich dominik und sascha
von ihrer beeindruckendsten seite
gezeigt
[Musik]
genau der richtige zeitpunkt und jagd zu
beenden
die luft das element zum schweben
atmen
und träumen
sie bringt immer wieder frischen wind in
unser leben
und hilft uns die antworten zwischen
himmel und erde zu finden
dank ihr schweben wir auf wolke sieben
und sie lässt uns dem stärksten sturm
standhalten
[Musik]
und egal wie dünn sie manchmal
sorgt sie dafür dass wir niemals
aufgeben
[Musik]